une production du studio
SF bienvenue sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut nos
invités pH Quentin avec moi Dom PL cette
semaine on reçit un honorable un
honorable un invité de marque quand même
sur le Podcast semaine un ministre au
fédéral le ministre Steven
guilb qui qui qui nous fait plaisir de
venir nous rencontrer de venir parler
avec nous d'environnement de
de son travail de sa vie de de sa lutte
de son militantisme environnemental en
fait c vraiment intéressant lui c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a toujours é engagé
dans la courise environnementale depuis
qui depuis qui est tout jeune raconté à
5 ans qui s qui qui grimperé dans un
arbre pour éviter qu'il soit coupé puis
que tout son militantisme est né de de
ça quelqu'un qui a fondé qui a fondé
caufondé l'organisme équitaire qui a
fait partie de Green Peace pendant une
dizaine d'années et que maintenant il
est ministre de l'Environnement avec
tous les défis que ça comporte c'est
super intéressant c'était vraiment un
échange super nuancé aussi puis je le
sentais extrêmement honnête sur les
difficultés de son travail des fois les
compromis qui sont pas faciles à faire
quand qu'on est au gouvernement puis que
on veut militer pour l'environnement
mais qu'en même temps il y a d'autres
des fois d'autres intérêts aussi
d'autres variables à considérer qui fait
que des fois les décisions font pas
toujours notre affaire euh un G super
TER à terre on le vu arrivver en vélo
fait que c'est pas de la FR son affaire
il est vraiment il vraiment en à moins
qu' conduise un H le reste du temp des
entrevues en vélo mais ça me
surprendrait exact tuas quelque chose à
ajouter non mais c'est une super
conversation c'est tout le temps
vraiment le fun de recevoir des gens
qu'on voit comme étant juste des
politiciens de rencontrer finalement la
personne derrière la personne politique
puis comme tu dis une conversation
vraiment honte sais on sent que il y a
pas de pas nement langue de bois là tu
sais à part lorsque questionner sur la
caque mais mais on sent que c'est un
gars super hon super terateur super
humain en fait fait que c'est vraiment
intéressant céit belle conversation on a
rencontré quand même sais au fil du
temps on s'en filtre là je j'ouvre une
parenthèse mais des gens de de
différents parties tu sais la plupart du
temps en fait sais tu te rends compte
ces gens là c'est vraiment des gens qui
sont là pour les bonnes raisons puis que
puis ça donne envie tu sais peu importe
la g politique tu sa je sais pas pour
qui je vais voter au fédéral la
prochaine élection peut-être que je
voterai pas pour ce parti là mais quand
même tu le sens que cette personn là est
là pour faire du mieux qu' peut qu'il
peut puis pour travailler pour
l'environnement moi j'ai l'impression
que les gens qui sont pas là pour les
bonnes raison ils refusent nos
invitations parce que quand tu es pas là
pour les bonnes raisons parler pendant
2h à amené ça peut paraître j'ai
l'impression absolument mais en tout cas
moi ça ça m'a donné envie de encore
faire confiance à ce gars je pense qu'on
peut le truster tout à fait fait que bon
podcast bon écoute le podcast de cette
semaine est présenté par l'alternateur
l'alternateur c'est un projet web sur
Instagram et Youtube qui traite
d'environnement c'est piloté par deux
animateurs Thomas et Zoé qui sont pas
des experts en environnement mais qui
sont des personnes curieuses qui posent
des questions qui cherchent à mieux
comprendre les enjeux environnementaux
qui nous guett donc c'est fait de façon
super dynamique super abordable estce
que j'aime principalement c'est que
c'est fait de façon positive on cherche
des réponses à nos questions par rapport
aux enjeux environnementaux parce que
souvent quand on parle l'environnement
on est souvent dans le pessimisme puis
ça peut être une cause d'anxiété pour
plusieurs ben là c'est fait dans le
positivisme et c'est fait de façon à
mieux comprendre en fait et trouver des
solutions aux enjeux qui nous guident
donc c'est de l'information pertinente
ça peut aller de de de trucs qu'on
peut-être qu'on sait pas comme par
exemple une capsule sur où va nos
vapoteuse jetable lorsqu'on les jette
puis c'est quoi les répercussions sur
l'environnement ça peut traiter de
sujets comme l'écoanxiété c'est de ça
peut parler de des plus récentes
actualités dans le monde environnemental
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans le monde euh
je pense que c'est super important et
pertinent d'être informé puis d'être
conscient de ces enjeux-là puis c'est
fait encore une fois on le dit d'une
manière super agréable super le fun
super ludique euh les animateurs sont
vraiment sont vraiment cool sont
vraiment le fun moi je les suis la page
j'apprends plein d'affaair j'adore ça
donc l'alternateur à checker à checker
soit les suivre sur Instagram ou sur
Youtube vous regretterez pas on va
mettre le lien vers leur plateforme dans
la description du podcast puis merci
alternateur de sponsoriser le sansf
podcast
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cool ça roule merci beaucoup d'être là
ça me fait plaisir on commence aussi
simplement que ça est-ce que l'horaire
est très chargé ces jour-ci l'horaire
est généralement assez chargé ou imagin
c'est des semaines de 70 80 he des fois
plus ou mais en moyenne ça tourne autour
de de ça ouais mais on apprécie quand
même le temps que tu prends pour venir
nous parler ça fera plaisir j'aimerais
ça commencer juste avec une
question la qui va nous amener dans des
je pensais qu'on commença j'éis assis
vous commenciz avec la pub je pensais
que vous allez me parler des
produits je me demandais en tant que
fier barbu si moi aussi j'avais le droit
ben si tu veux participer à publicité en
fait souvent les tourne
après mais tu pouras en faire partie
aujourd'hui parler des produits que tu
utilises pour la barentretien la barbe
et sous la
ceinture quand tu as qure enfants tu
travailles 70 80 heur par semaine puis
t'entraî un peu il faut a des fa tu
fasses des choix mon entretien
capillaire sur
limite en haut de la
ceinture
intéressant je savais pas j'aisendre
aud'uiéis votre dernier notamment votre
dernier Podcast quand même un segment
assez important dans la partie publicité
sur le l'entretien en bas de la ceinture
là je me disais non pour moi c'est
comme pass d' dans une
semaine wouh mais écoute on fait les
comment qu'on a des fiers partenaires de
longue
dateou mais j'avoue que c'est peble sur
certain podcast ça dans le ton ça
fonctionne très bien puis dans avec
d'autres des fois on dit ah semble cette
pu BL avec C invité là moins bon
Fitou mais là ça ça marche Faale pour
moi ça
marche on va le garder on va le garder
pu on s'assurer de parler plus de la
barbe deous la aujourd'hui vous voulez
une barbe aussi incroyable que
Steven W euh ouais ouais je voulais
excusez on est parti un c'est parfait
c'est parfait j'adore ça euh mais je
voulais poser une question en fait tu
mentionnes que tu es pères de famille
évidemment je voulais poser une question
au père de famille qui V nous amener euh
on verra où ça nous amène
es-tu pour le futur optimiste plus ou
moins optimiste plus ou moins pessimiste
pessimiste euh pour la planète que tes
enfants vont avoir dans 20 30 ans moi
j'ai j'ai eu la l'immense chance et
privilège de de de croiser d'avoir pu
échanger à de nombreuses reprise avec
uber rims qui qui qui est décédé
récemment qui était comme on le sait bon
CIT un astrophysicien mais c'était aussi
un grand écologiste depuis très très
très longtemps puis il s'intéressait
beaucoup à ces questions là c'est dans
ce cadre là qu'on qu'on s'est vu à à
plusieurs reprises puis il disait
toujours tu sais il faut être optimiste
par défaut parce que si on est
pessimiste c'est perdu
d'avance alors moi je je suis totalement
d'accord avec ça puis quand je regarde
ça fait à peu près 35 ans que que je
suis écologiste mettons que c'est ce que
je fais principalement dans la vie et on
a fait beaucoup de progrès à plusieurs
égards puis les gens tu sa souvent les
gens veulent des des résultats rapides
puis quand tu essaes de t'attaquer à des
problématiques globales c'est dur de
faire du r ça prend du temps mais on moi
je pense que on on est sur une voie en
matière de changement climatique on va
éviter le pays mais il y en a déjà tu
sais puis on a on l' vu avec les feux de
forêt cet été puis pas jouer à
l'autruche non plus là mais il y a il y
a un mouvement planétaire assez fort
pour qu'on va pour qu'on réussisse à à
éviter le pire même chose sur la la
biodiversité on perd beaucoup d'espèces
mais là il a eu la conférence à Montréal
la COP 15 puis tout le monde c'est
malgré toutes les les problèmes
internationaux on a travaillé avec la
Chine puis tous les autres pays puis on
a réussi à avoir une entente la
pollution plastique on est en train de à
plusieurs il y a vraiment un mouvement
international pour éliminer la pollution
plastique d'ici à peu près 15 ans tu
sais ça fait longtemps là qu'onu du
plastique là puis là on va je pense
qu'on va réussir aussi alors mais en
même temps sa on paye le
prix l'environnement au niveau de la
santé il document ire qui va sortir
bientôt sur les microplastiques c'est un
ami à moi qui a fait ça il a travaillé
pendant des années là-dessus et il a
fait le tour il est allé un peu partout
dans le monde de rencontrer des
chercheurs des médecins il trouvent des
des microplastiques dans notre cerveau
notre corps réussi à en éliminer mais il
y en a qui qui qui s'accumule dans puis
là ça a des impacts sur notre santé ça a
des impacts sur l'environnement alors je
je suis optimiste mais en même temps tu
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de travail à
faire h puis le pire qu quand tu dis on
va éviter le pire le pire ça ça ça
serait quoi en fait ça si on faisait
rien c'est le mettons sais je pense qu'
en fait avec les cibles qu'on se donne
on on vise si
2 si je me trompe une augmentation de
2.5 deg celus ben la cororde de Paris
dit il faut limiter les augmentations de
température à 2 degés celus d'ici 200 2
degr celus de plus que avant l'air
industriel ouais puis essayer essayer de
rester donc au plus 2. puis essayer
d'être autour de 1.5 degr
celus là depuis l'air industrielle la
température moyenne a augmenté d'à peu
près 1 degr celus alors les feux de
forêt qu'on a eu cet été les inondations
les temptes tropicales les vagues de
chaleur c'est avec 1 degr celus plus il
y a de réchauffement plus il y a
d'impact plus il y a de catastrophe
naturelle mais donc 2 degrés c'est déjà
le pire tu sais c'est déjà je dire il y
a pire mais c'est déjà très mal très
mauvais je c'est très mal effectivement
puis il faut voir aussi qu'avant
l'accord de Paris on se dirigeait selon
le le JC le Groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur le climat de
l'ONU puis l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie ces gens-là nous disaient
qu'on se dirigeait dans un monde où la
température augmenterait d'ici 20000 de
4 4.5 deg C c'est cataclysmique c'est là
c'est vraiment ou oui c'est c'est tu as
des des des des des centaines de
millions de personnes qui pour qui ne
pourraient plus vivre là où ils vivent
présentement dans plusieurs région de la
planète il y a des
coins qui qui dev qui deviendrait et qui
dans certains cas qui devient peut-être
malgré ça invivable mais mais là on a
réussi collectivement grâce à tout le
travail qui se fait un peu partout ça a
pris du temps moi je fa j'étais à la
première conférence des partis des
nations- Unies en 1995 la COP 1 là on
s'en va à la la
28e la fin du mois de novembre est-ce
que juste juste une mini parenthèse sur
cette cette période de temps là est-ce
que le sentiment d'urgence dans ces
rencontres là était aussi présent en
95 en
95 je pense qu'il y a le de voir qui
avait fait un article pendant les 2
semaines sa de la conférence puis euh
sais les
journalistes la population en général la
plupart des décideurs pensaient que
c'était des écolons puis tu sa des des
chercheurs un peu crackp dans leur coin
qui inventaient des problème tu
sais l'urgence on la sent depuis à peu
près une décennie mais pendant pendant
20 ans tu sais on aurait pu parce que ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
scientifique on le savait pas mal il y a
30 ans la science est plus
on c'est plus raffiné nos connaissances
sont meilleures on est on est meilleur à
anticiper les les problèmes à les voir
venir la tempête tropicale Fiona qui a
frappé les provinces atlantiqu l'an
passé environnement Canada a prédit à
quelques centaines de mètres près où
elle allait passer fait qu'on a réussi à
faire évacuer des gens puis finalement
il y a pas eu trop de a quand même eu
des décès mais il y en a eu peu alors ça
ça ça s'est amélioré mais en gros ce
qu'on sa aujourd'hui on le savait il y a
30 il y a 35 ans mais les gouvernements
ont pas pris ça au sérieux puis là
depuis ont commencé à prendre ça au
sérieux on n fait pas encore assez puis
c'est vrai pour le Canada aussi mais là
les experts nous disent qu'on se dirige
avec les engagements qu' a présentement
on se dirige vers un monde où
l'augmentation de température serait de
l'ordre de 1.7 à 2.5 alors c'est encore
trop donc il faut continuer quand les
gens me disent vous en faites trop on
dit moins ça au Québec mettons qu'en
Alberta ou mais vous en fait vous en
faites trop monsieur le ministre moi je
leur dis ben vous voulez dans quel monde
vous voulez vivre puis dans quel monde
vous voulez que vos enfants vivent puis
vos petits enfants tu sais alors plus on
agit rapidement plus on travaille fort
pour pour pour réduire puis
éventuellement éliminer notre dépend
parce que c'est essentiellement c'est le
pétrole le gaz naturel puis le charbon
une fois qu'on a réglé ça on a bon il y
a l'agriculture mais c'est c'est c'est
quand tu t'attaques à ça quand on va
avoir réussi puis au Canada le charbon
on est en train d'éliminer ça ça va
super bien partout dans le monde il y a
une exception une exception notable
c'est la Chine
mais le charbon est en perte de vitesse
partout les pays réduisent de plus en
plus leur utilisation de charbon alors
ça donc moi je pense que le charbon
d'ici 2030 ça va être largement réglé là
il nous reste le gaz naturel puis le
pétrole les C qu'on se donne sais on va
d les atteindre réalistiquement parce
que historiquement à chaque fois qu'on
don les cibres les cibles c'est pas
passé au Canada c'est vrai on a pu il y
a un gros débat autour des cibes aussi
on perd tellement de temps à parler des
cibes à essayer de mettre des
puis finalement tellement pas assez de
temps à les atteindre c'est un excellent
point moi quand j'étais quand le Parti
libéral a gagné l'élection en 2015 là il
y avait tout un débat chez les
écologistes j'étais àquitire à
l'époque Premier ministre trudau a dit B
on va garder les cibles actuelles mais
on va travailler avoir un plan pour les
atteindre avant d'avoir des nouvelles
cibles puis les cibles qui étaient là
c'était celle de de STEP un pe Steven
UNP avait effectivement c'est
conservatrice dans tous les sens du
monde
puis mais mais un peu avait avait mis en
place aucune mesure il y avait aucun
plan pour atteindre ces C puis le
Premier ministre Rudo a dit écoutez
donnons-nous les moyens d'atteindre ces
cbles puis là quand on sera confiant
qu'on est capable on ira une c plus
ambitieuse puis après son plus
ambitieuse puis moi je faisais partie du
camp chez les écoles tout le monde était
pas d'accord mais qui disait exactement
ça tu sais ça fait 30 ans qu'on parle de
cible au Canada on peut tu parler de la
mise en œuvre puis de comment on va
faire puis là ben ce qui est arrivé
depuis 2015 c'est qu'on au départ donc
les cibles étaient de réduire d'au moins
30 % de nos émissions de gaz à effet de
Sal d'ici 2030 là on a réisé ça à 38 %
après un premier plan d'action puis là
on a commencé à mettre en place nos
mesures puis on s'est dit bon on est
capable d'aller plus loin fait que là
notre CIB actuel c'est 40 à 45 % d'ici
2030 donc c'est beaucoup plus que
c'était il y a à peine 8 ans puis moi je
suis très confiant qu'on va les
atteindre on a présenté un plan l'an
passé tu sa un espèce de rapport d'étape
qui montrre on est rendu où qu'est-ce
qui reste à faire on est déjà à peu près
à 25 % de l'teinte de notre CPE de 2030
on est en 2023 donc il nous reste 7 ans
pour faire le reste du chemin al je suis
pas en train de dire que c'est dans la
poche puis qu' on peut tout s'en
retourner chez nous puis s'occuper de
notre jardin puis laisser faire c ces
débat là sur le pétrole puis puis gaz
naturel pas du tout mais moi je suis
confiant moi quand je regarde les les
les problèmes climatiques puis la les
courbe qu'on voit
de l'aspect exponentiel de ces trucs on
dirait que je me dis que la solution
passe par des euh des solutions
exponentiell aussi tu sais puis est-ce
que c'est ça qu'on qu'on est en train de
faire est-ce que la technologie est
capable de exponentiellement rattraper
euh le les effets néfastes des
changement climatique
ben la la technologie on a on a deux
problèmes dans que ce soit la pollution
plastique que ce soit soit la
biodiversité que ce soit les changements
climatiques on a des problèmes de
technologie puis on a des problèmes de
choix de société
ouais la technologie va donc on parlait
du pétrole et du gaz un problème
technologique puis bon la technologie va
nous aider là-dedans mais la technologie
nous aidera pas ou en tout cas pas
beaucoup à régler nos problèmes de choix
de
société pendant des décennies au Canada
puis dans plusieurs autres
pays puis en fait ils le font encore
dans dans les autres pays mais les pays
du G20 fournissent à peu près 700
milliards de dollars de subvention
combustible fossile par année une
subvention tu sais qui va juste à ce
secteur
là le Canada on les a on les a éliminé
cette année c'est complètement on est le
premier pays du G20 à avoir fait ça puis
l'objectif cétait de le faire pour 2025
nous on a dit on va faire 2 ans plusut
tôt que prévu euh il reste encore des
subventions Canada qui sont par des des
ce qu'on appelle du financement public
euh donc pour l'organisation mondiale de
du commerce une une subvention c'est un
c'est un transfert d'argent direct du
gouvernement vers une entreprise mais
dans le cas sais c'est des subventions
qui allit juste au secteur du pétrole ou
juste au secteur du gaz maintenant les
gens disent ouais mais vous avez encore
des vous subventionnez encore les
pétroliages ben attention là je dis on a
des subventions pour aider à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
tous les secteurs d'activité que ce soit
les cimenteries les alumineries la
production d'acier puis si les
pétrolières veulent utiliser ces
subventions là ils peuvent aussi mais
c'est pas une subvention qui qui est
juste là pour les aider eux un puis de
c'est pas une subvention qui est là pour
les aider à faire plus de pétrole ou de
gaz c'est une subvention qui est là pour
les aider à réduire la pollution h ça
c'est un choix ce 700 milliards là c'est
bien encadré l'utilisation de ces
subventions
là ben je veux dire une fois que la
compagnie reçoit la subvention pour
réduire sa pollution est-ce qu'il y a
comme des il y a des suivis qui sont
faits puis nous on fait des suivis en
tant gouvernement puis on est surveillé
par les ONG on est surveillé par les
partis d'opposition par le le
commissaire à l'environnement fait
est-ce que 100 % des des est-ce que 100
% des compagnies sont sont clean dans
dans tout ça peut-être pas mais
largement puis tu sais au Canada on est
en train de réduire les émissions en
2019 et 2021 on a réduit de 50 millions
de tonnes là les gens vont dire ouais il
y avait la pandémie c'est vraim en 2021
on éétait plus vraiment en pandémie
l'économie du Canada a été la plus
performante de tous les pays du G7 cette
année-là puis encore l'année passée puis
malgré ça on a réduit d'à peu près l'
équivalent d'enlever 11 millions de
véhicules de de sur nos routes fait not
c'est c'est quoi bah c'est le prix sur
la pollution qu'on a mis au Canada c'est
des mesures pour forcer dans le secteur
du pétrole et du gaz à réduire les
émissions de méthane gaz effet très
puissant le méthane va être réduit dans
ce secteur là d'au moins 40 % d'ici 2000
25 donc dans 2 ans puis 75 au moins 75 %
d'ici 2030 c'est un des objectifs les
plus ambitieux sur la planète h puis si
on réussit collectivement là tu sais des
on parle de solution technologique le
méthane là c'est pas compliqué dans le
secteur du pétrole et du gaz tu sais le
méthane c'est du gaz naturel qui qui
fuit tu sais dans dans les procédés
industriels dans les gazoduc donc les
solutions technologiques sont assez
simples à mettre en place pour réduire
cette pollution là puis si on fait ça
collectivement tu au Canada aux
États-Unis puis en Chine puis c'est
presque 1 degr celus de moins
d'augmentation de température si on fait
juste le méthane tout le monde dans le
secteur du pétrole fait sais moi je suis
allé en Chine cet été pu là les
conservateurs disaient que j'étais un
espion chinois mais tu sais si on
réussit à s oui on il y a plein
d'affaires avec lesquels on est pas
d'accord oui j'ai un peu espionné mais
pas
ça mais tu sais si on réussit à
s'entendre avec la Chine puis là je vais
parler à l'Arabie Saoudite aussi parce
que tu
sais puis cette année en plus la la
conférence de l'UNU a lieu dans un grand
pays producteur de de pétrole et de gaz
les Émirats arabes unis h mais j'ai eu
plusieurs rencontres avec le président
de la conférence pour dire tu sa tu es
un grand producteur n au Canada on est
un grand producteur on peut travailler
ensemble sur ces affaires
làit je pense que comme ça ça nous aide
à régler une partie du problème mais
après ça il y a des choix de société tu
sais puis tous les on en parlait tout à
l'heure les débats sur les
stationnements est qu'on fait plus de
cyclable plus plus ça va être facile
pour moi ça fait 35 ans que je fais du
vélo à Montréal il y a 35 ans il y avait
trois p
C sur Rachel il y avait celle sur le
boulevard Gouin puis il y en avait
peut-être une autre sais puis cétait pas
super c'était alors que là il y en a
beaucoup plus ah il y a plus de gens qui
se déplacent en vélo il y a moins d'auto
l'année passée au Québec notre
consommation d'essence a
diminué de c'est c'est la plus basse
consommation depuis à peu près une
décennie pas même quand tu compares à la
pandémie pourquoi ben les gens plus de
gens qui se déplacent en vélo il y a
plus de transport pas en commun il y a
plus de voitures électrique aussi on est
rendu à peu près au Québec à quel chose
comme 15 ou 16 % des ventes de de de de
véhicules sont des véhicules électriques
moi je pense pas que le véhicule
électrique c'est la la solution à toutes
nos problèmes je pense c'est une partie
de la solution pour plein de gens qui
ont besoin de véhicule puis qui vont
continuer d'avoir besoin de véhicule
alors ça pu sais ça c'est des choix de
société comment c'est comment on aménage
nos villes quelle place on fait à la
voiture combien on investit dans le
transport
collectif mais est-ce que que mais des
technologies auxquelles tu sais là on
entend parler de recapture de de CO2 de
carbone tu sais des nouvelles
technologies comme ça qui peuvent nous
donner espoir que tu sais qu'on peut
renverser carrément là tu sais les les
effets tu sais tis que oui freiner
freiner c'est une chose sa oui mais tu
sais vraiment quelque chose de qui était
pas possible avant que là peut-être la
technologie peut-être des nouvell des
nouvelles innovations pourrai créer B tu
as raison que tu sais ce que les
scientifiques nous dit c'est que ça se
pourrait dans les prochaines années
qu'on dépasse le 1.5°r celus mais faut
pas baisser les bras parce qu'on si on
travaille fort on est capable de même si
on dépasse de de ramener ça par la suite
donc de de faire en sorte qu'on qu'on
que les températures redescendent en bas
d' 1.5 puis peut-être même encore plus
euh ça passe en partie par des
technologies comme comme la capture du
carbone même si je pense que c'est pas
une solution magique c'est il faut
réduire notre dépendance au pétrole
puis là on va consommer encore du
pétrole en 200 dans un monde carboneutre
mais pas nécessairement peu probable
qu'on le mettre encore dans des voitures
ou peut-être dans le secteur de
l'aviation on va en utiliser encore
mais on va en avoir de besoin mais
beaucoup moins qu'aujourd'hui puis pour
ce pétrole là qui va rester ben là il va
falloir capturer les émissions puis les
les séquestrer le reboisement c'est une
bonne façon c'est une vieille
technologie technologie ça s'appelle des
arbres c'est une nouvelle affaire c'est
vraiment puis ça tu sais il y a des
programmes massifs de reboisement un peu
partout à l'échelle de la planète parce
qu'on sait que ça peut nous aider ça on
narrivera pas juste en plantant des
armes mais ça ça peut faire une
différence importante aussi tu parlais
de choix de société
puis quand euh j'imagine que tu arrives
en politique puis
que tes idées idéalistes peut-être
d'ancien militant écologiste se frappe à
l'espèce de concurrence entre pays vers
la la progression pu la croissance c'est
comment ces discussions là quand toi
mettons tu parles à ton homologue
chinois mais qu'au final les décisions
se prennent quand même en haut pour la
croissance économique puis les espèces
de de jeux de puissance entre les pays
comment est-ce que ça se passe ces
discussions
là
c'est c'est sûr que quand je quand j'ai
pris la décision de d'aller en politique
ça m'a pris bien du temps de décider ça
moi j'ai quitté équitire en octobre 2018
puis j'ai j'ai annoncé que je me
présentais pour le Parti libéral en juin
2019 puis avant de quitterquitire je
pensais déjà puis j'ai quittéquit parce
que j'étais plus sûr tu sais je savais
pas si j'allais y aller ou j'allais pas
y aller mais je me disais bon sais je
peux-tu rester chez équitire je peuxtu
continuer d'être porte-parole d'équitire
alors que je me demande si je veis être
candidat pour le Parti libéral ça m'a
pris des mois de me décider à à y aller
puis une partie de la réflexion c'était
ça tu sais est-ce que est-ce que je vais
réussir à faire avancer les choses pu
sais quand j'étais chez kit j'étais
essentiellement un lobbyiste
environnemental c'est ça que je faisais
je rencontrais des députés des ministres
je travaillis sur des projets de loi des
projets de règlement sur les budgets
alors j'avais une assez bonne idée mais
quand tu arrives en politique tu
découvre un paquet d'affaires que tu
comprenais pas que tu voyais pas quand
tu étais pas en politique al il y a un
apprentissage puis ça fait 4 ans
maintenant puis je te dirais que
j'apprends encore beaucoup à comprendre
le fonctionnement de l'appareil
gouvernemental les ministères le Conseil
du Trésor le cabinet le Parlement les
projets de loi on est un gouvernement
minoritaire faut travailler avec
l'opposition le bloc P l'pd les
conservateurs mett que pas beaucoup il a
pas beaucoup de collaborations là
euh
alors sais je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus facile maintenant pour quelqu'un
comme moi d'arriver dans un gouvernement
ben ça dépend lequel mais dans le
gouvernement de Donald Trump je suis pas
sûr mais d'être capable de faire avancer
ces choses là tu sais je suis pas tout
seul au cabinet à penser qu'il faut
lutter contre les changements
climatiques j'ai vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'appui je su pas comme le
l'écolon extrémiste dans le coin là tu
sais c'est un peu la même chose au
niveau international tu sais il y a une
prise de conscience
global de de ces
enjeuxl c'est vrai tu sais je veux dire
en Europe par exemple particulièrement
en Scandinavie par exemple tu as desas
des gouvernements de droite qui sont pro
lutte au changement climatique tu sais
il en fait il y a il y a quelques pays
tu l'Australie
euh le Canada les États-Unis
ou les gouvernements de droite sont
antienvironnement mais dans la plupart
des pays un des pays avec lequel
c'est presque une épiphanie un des pays
avec lequel j'ai j'ai le plus collaboré
depuis que je suis ministre
d'environnement c'est le gouvernement de
droite populiste de Boris Johnson en
Grande-Bretagne Boris Johnson m'a appelé
au début de la COP 15 on a fait un zoom
ensemble puis là il m'appelait pour me
me féliciter d'avoir accepté de d'être
l'aut de la COP 15 puis travailler avec
la Chine puis je peux tout t'aider
Steven puis tu sais écoute dans la vie
là j'ai pas grandchose en commun avec
byis Johnson tu sais mais c'est un c'est
un c'est un populiste de droite pro
environnement ces deux idées qui sont
pas mutuellement exclusives exact puis
je pense qu'on on voit ça de plus en
plus sa c'est pas tout le monde mais nos
conservateurs tu sais au Québec on a la
cax particulièrement partie de gauche
mais sur l'environnement sont quand même
sais on est capable de travailler
ensemble il font ils font quand même
beaucoup de choses je dirais pas que
c'est parfait mais il y a un dialogue
qui est possible puis une collaboration
qui est possible pas comme ça partout
nécessairement d'un côté si on revient à
la racine du mot conservateur je veux
dire il y a rien de plus il rien de plus
traditionnel que la nature là on est
supposé vouloir la conserver exact puis
c'est c'est les partis conservateurs ont
été les parmi les premiers à lancer des
programmes de de conservation je veux
dire ça ça all soit bon entre autres
parce qu'il y il y a beaucoup de
chasseurs et pêcheurs puis qui veulent
pouvoir continuer à pratiquerouis là fa
qu' se dit ben ça prend quand il y aura
plus de r ça prend la place pour faire
ça tu mais bon écoute si c'est sais je
veux dire si c'est ça qui les motive en
autant qu'il a de la conservation qui se
fasse moi je ça marche ouais mais c'est
pas le cas ici au Canada for Reason mais
en fait ça tu sais à l'époqueis on a eu
des grands ministres de l'Environnement
conservateur
fédéral Lucien Bouchard un conservateur
Jean Charet un conservateur c'est Jean
Charet qui représentait le Canada la
conférence de Rio en 1992
puis le Canada vraiment tiré les
États-Unis on les le le c'est le premier
ministre BR m Ron qui a invité son ami
George bouchepre à venir à Rio il
voulait pas venir il voulait pas signer
la convention il a fait finalement
beaucoup à cause du Canada fa il était
une époque où les conservateurs étaient
pro environnement au Canada mais là
depuis Stephen Harper puis bon Andrew
sheer puis puis monsieur autour puis là
avec Pier
c'est encore pire là je dire c'est une
forme de conservatime qu'on a jamais vu
encore au Canada c'est vraiment une
formule canadienne de de Donald Trump
puis de
bolsonaro au Brésil puis les autres
Orban en Hongrie puis puis ce ce
changement de de mentalité là est-ce que
tu crois que c'est aussi
par
viser d'aller chercher des votes d'aller
chercher étion parce que quandon parle
d'environnement la chose principale
qu'on dit aux gens c'est il va falloir
changer votre vieoir changer vosos votre
façon de vivre tu sais changer nos
habitudes de vie pour pour amoindrir
notre impact carbone puis c'est
probablement la chose que les gens
veulent le moins entendre de se faire
dire vous allez devoir changer la façon
avec laquelle vous vivez puis est-ce que
quand c'est devenu vraiment un enjeu
pressant de dire non faut vraiment ch
mais là la posture inverse de dire non
non non vous avez pas besoin de changer
devenu une posture
électoraliste alors en politique tu veux
toujours gagner des votes
entendons-nous là-dessus mais après ça
tu
sais je pense
que si on regarde au Parlement à tawa la
majorité des Canadiens et canadien ont
voté pour des représentants et des
partis politiques qui sont pro lutte au
changement climatique le québécois le
NPD le Parti libéral les vers puis tu
sais on va là il va avoir une élection
éventuellement puis il va avoir des
débats puis là on va débattre des
questions environnementales puis là tu
sais il y a le parti ver va dire les
libéraux vous en faites passer puis on n
pas d'accord sur tout là mais on est
d'accord sur un ces quatre partis là on
est d'accord sur un paquet d'affaires
puis là tuas le Parti conservateur tu
sais qui est complètement part fait
qu'il y a une minorité de Canadiens et
de Canadiennes qui votent pour un parti
qui veut rien savoir la majorité des des
gens sont sont pas là puis moi je suis
tu
sais je fais toujours attention au
discours un peu alarmiste ouais mais
sais on propose pas aux gens de
retourner à l'âge de pierre on n pas
là-dedans mais oui il va avoir puis on
parlait de c'est des changements de
comportement on le voit déjà tu sais je
on parlait de l'aménagement du
territoire puis de l'utilisation moiis
il y a 30 ans des gens qui utilisaient
le vélo comme moyen de transport on on
était 10 à Montréal on se connaissait
toutes là tu sais je veux dire on
s'appelait par notre prénom là là
aujourd'hui tu as des tu sais tu as des
centaines de milliers de personnes
partout au pays c'est vrai beaucoup au
Québec mais c'est vrai ailleurs au pays
qui qui ont fait ce choix là tu sais il
y a une voiture de moins des fois dans
famille puis où il y a deux voitures
mais il l'utilise beaucoup moins pour
les gens qui qui habitent plus loin tu
sais on investit plus en transport en
commun là il y a grâce aux
investissements fédéraux il y a plus de
1200 proj projet de transport en commun
en construction àchat d'autobus
électrique mon mon collègue le ministre
le blanc il y a quelques mois annoncé
1200 autobus électriques pour le
québecis je suis pas sûr que les gens
qui décident de choisir de prendre le
transport en commun de prendre le vélos
dis je sacrifie aujourd'hui tu sais un
choix de vie ils le font probablement
parce qu'ils trouvent ça plus pratique
plus agréable plus plus économique aussi
ça coûte moins cher ouais définitivement
on au niveau de la pollution plastique
tu sais pourquoi est-ce que il y a plus
de sac plastique à peu près nulle
part oui notre gouvernement mis en place
des mesures pour les éliner puis mais à
la base c'est les gens qui ont arrêté de
prendre des sacs de plastique quand les
gouvernements sont arrivés dans quand
les gouvernements ont légiféré là-dessus
que ce soit Québec ou
atawa les gens avaient déjà à 90 %
arrêté de de de prendre des sacs de
plastique moi je parlais aux gens des
des grandes bannières au puis tout ça
puis il me disait plus personne qui nous
demande ça on en a gardé je parlais à
l'ancien PDG de Ron il disit on en avait
gardé 10 % puis on les utilise même pas
h h ça céit avant qu'on en mettre en
place fait tu sais je pense qu' y a il y
a une sagesse populaire aussi des fois
puis bon les les gens sont pas toujours
d'accord tu sais là je me fais planter
en en Atlantique à cause de la
tarification
carbone parce que on a été un peu
laxiste on a mis ça en place au Canada
en 2019 puis dans ces provinces là on
ont été un peu laxiste avec la mise en
œuvre puis ils avaient des systèmes puis
disait que c'était équivalent de
tarification mais ça l'était pas
vraiment puis là l'année passée j'ai
serré la vis à tout le monde à travers
le pays fait que là eux ça il y a eu
comme un rattrapage tu sais de ils ont
dû faire en quelques mois ce qu'on a
fait dans le reste du pays depuis 3 4
ans puis au Québec même depuis plus
longtemps que ça parce qu'on a pris sur
la pollution au Québec depuis bien avant
le Canada alors là tu sais je passe au
bat là je peux même pas aller euh tu
sais là j'avais j'avais un voyage de
prévu àifax puis les gens m'ont dit
écoute peut-être tu devrais attendre
avant avant de venir je peux aller en
Alberta non plus je peux pas aller SAS
une chance je peux aller au BC au Québec
ça va les Territoires du
Nord-Ouest le nounav là je suis encore
bienvenu mais alors c'est pas pour dire
que tu sais donc c'est plus facile mais
c'est pas toujours facile tu sais des
fois il y a des vents face ça serait
facile pour le Premier ministre de me
dire écoute Steven l'Alberta est en
guerre contre moi la saskatoan dog Ford
a dit de moi que j'étais en anglais a
piece of work euh la la première
ministre de la bertepite
elle dit ça deait arrêté de parler ouis
il a pas il y a pas se passe rement une
semaine sans qu'elle PL pas sur les
médias sociaux là à jour d' avec ma face
dans son bureau vous de Steven sû
s tu le Premier ministre pourrait dire
écoute Steven slque un peu là tu
sais mais non il dit pas il dit Go dans
la dernière année on a a on a adopté un
règlement ce qu'on appelle la norme sur
les carburants propres donc pour forcer
les les les distributeurs de de de de
d'essence et de diesel à réduire leur
empreinte de
carbone on a on a présenté le projet de
règlement pour la la loi zéro émission
que Québec a déjà depuis très longtemps
moi j'ai travaillé là-dessus au Québec
quand j'étais chez kit le bici en a déjà
une donc pour forcer les fabricants
d'automobiles à mettre plus de voiture
zéro émission donc essentiellement des
des voitures électriques sur le marché
puis au Canada ça sera 100 % ici 2035
comme le comme le Québec a déjà un
règlement là-dessus
aussi j'ai présenté un règlement pour
que le réseau électrique soit carbon
d'ici 2035 au Québec au Québec on on
voit pas ça là mais en NouvelleÉcosse 60
% de l'électricité produite c'est encore
du charbon ah ouais la saskatuan le
Manitoba le nouveau bronzewick on
utilise encore beaucoup de combustible
fossile pour produire de l'électricité
alors on a fait ça aussi je vais
présenter un projet de règlement pour
mettre un un plafond sur les émissions
de gaz effet s du secteur du pétrole et
du gaz tout ça dans les deux dernières
années ouais euh tu sais pu quand je
disais plutôt il y a des gens dans
certains coins du pays qui disent ben là
tu tu trouves pas que tu vas faire un
peu puis moi je dis ben non on n pas le
choix tu sais c'est quasiment pas assez
encore là tu sais c'est non ben c'est
pas assez encore tu as raison tu sais il
faut il faut en faire plus ça c'est la
liste des bons coups aussi mais je
dirais il y a certainement des des
décisions de votre gouvernement avec
lesquelles tu aurais tu aurais voulu
aller dans l'autre sens puiss sont allés
là je pense entre autres projet de Bie
du Nord tu sais de de de nouveaux
nouveaux projets pétroliers récent que
que j'ai de la misèire à imaginé que le
le militant au fond de Steph guilbaau
qui est encore làu à tour du C c'est
gars là je la mis à l'imaginer être
d'accord avec ça cétait une journée tof
tu sais on tu me posais la question
tantôt tu sais le certain idéalisme
avant d'arriver en politique tu sais je
je savais de façon sont un peu
intellectuel que il y aurait des moments
où tu sais je je gagneris pas tout tu
sais pas tant que tu es pas rendu dans
ce moment c'est une chose tu sais de de
dire il va sûrement avoir des moments
puis là de d'être dedans puis de le
vivre
euh c'est cette journée là c'était t
là c'est la pire journée de ma vie c'est
sûr là tu sais puis les écolos avec
raison on on dénoncé tes anciens amis
collègues là ça va pas être facile quand
même ENIT je dirais encore amis ancien
collègue oua la bonne nouvelle c'est que
j'ai pas perdu d'amis depuis que je suis
arrivé il y a des gens qui m'aimaient
pas quand j'étais àve guit qui ne m'aim
qui m'aiment encore moi
aujourd'hui
mais mais mes anciens collègues et
toujours amis m' m'ont sévèrement
critiqué cette journée làà puis c'est ce
qu'il devait faire euh mais jeis arrivé
chez nous ce soir là tu sais puis quand
on était à tawa on travaille tout le
temps là je veux dire tu arrivve à 8h le
soir puis là tuas encore 1 heure ou deux
de lectures à faire pour tes rencontres
du lendemain et puis les briefing h TU
chez vous tout seul puis c'est t tu sais
c céit une journée mais là les mes mes
ancien collègue est toujours amis ont
commença à m'écrire pour me dire tu sais
on était r avec toi aujourd'hui là mais
tu es quand même notre ministre de
l'Environnement préféré fait tu dis
ouais tu sais les gens je pense
comprennent que je par de de quatre
enfants je gagne jamais toutes mes
batailles à la maison je gagnerai pas
toutes mes batailles dans un pay de 40
millions de personnes mais je comprends
que tu sais faire la politique c'est
faire des compromis c'est c'est il a il
y a beaucoup de variables
l'environnement est une des variables
parmi d'autres pour un gouvernement puis
qu'il faut prendre tout en compte pu ça
mais c'est
quoi j'ai de la mis quand même à à à à
voir pourquoi qu'on fait un nouveau
projet pétrolier en 2000 de aujourd'hui
là tu sais c'est quoi c'est c'est c'est
c'est quoi la la décision c'est quoi le
thinking der cette décision là en fait
bon c'est la première fois
qu' c'est la première fois qu'on demande
qu'on exige en fait pas une demande
c'est une exigence de que ce projet là
soit carbon d'ici 2050 c'est le premier
projet dans l'histoire du pays o on le
on leur demande de faire ça à la c'est
l'extraction qui est carb c'est c'est
l'extraction parce que on le brûle quand
même à l'autre bout la G ai ou ouais
effectivement ben en fait d'après
d'après le le J je disais que le pétrole
qu'on va utiliser en 2050 on le brûlera
plus dans nos autos on est à on on
consomme à peu près aujourd'hui 100 105
millions de barils de pétrole par jour à
l'échelle mondiale d'après les scénarios
du JC et des autres il on va en
consommer encore à peu près 25 millions
en 2050 dans un monde carboneutre ce
pétrole là qu'on va consommer on on le
brûlera plus beaucoup on va s'en servir
pour faire de l'asphat on va s'en servir
pour faire des des des des lubrifiants
mais la la combustion du pétrole en 2050
il y en restera plus beaucoup même si
donc tu dis bon ok j'approuve ce
projet-là parce qu'on va avoir encore
besoin de pétrole c'est un projet qui va
é mettre moins tu sa je c'est vrai que
j'ai dit ouais ce projet-là mais je suis
aussi le premier ministre de
l'environnement dans l'histoire du
Canada à dire non un projet de
sbitumineu qui aurait mis 10 fois plus
que le projet de baie du Nord fait que
tu dis bon ok tu sais on puis on a dit
oui a juste un projet en dans les deux
dernières années tu sais la Norvège qui
est un modèle euh à plusieurs égards
vient d'annoncer 18 milliards de dollars
d'investissement dans le le pétrole et
le gaz dans dans la mer du Nord puis les
États-Unis le président Biden a annoncé
une centaine de projets dans le golf du
Mexique fait que je me dis bon ok nous
on en a annoncé un je me suis fait
rentrer dedans avec raison honnêtement
je je doute que il y a beaucoup d'autres
projets pétroli après celulà tu sais je
regarde moi je je j'ai un peu j'ai j'ai
la chance de pouvoir voir les projets
qui vont être présentés à l'Agence
d'évaluation environnementale puis
présent puis quand un projet est
présenté une évaluation environnementale
d'un projet comme ça au Canada ça prend
3 5 ans tu sais il y a beaucoup de
compagnies pétrolières qui se disent ok
moi je là je va présenter un projet puis
là il va avoir une évaluation puis dans
3 5 ans je si tout va bien je vais avoir
mes permis pour commencer à à faire ça
est-ce que le monde va encore même au
Canada la Régie de l'énergie du Canada
présenté un rapport au printemps mois de
juin dernier qui qui regarde qui dit
essentiellement que la production de
pétrole au Canada va plafonner vers 2027
2028 puis que là dépendamment des
scénarios des hypothèses que tu que tu
regardes la production de pétrole au
Canada va diminuer d'un/3 à 2/3 d'ici
2050f qu'on c'est c'est je c'est logique
là on peut pas penser qu'on va continuer
à produire autant de pétrole ou à
consommer autant de pétrole alors qu'on
électrifie nos transports qu'on
électrifie nos industries euh tu sais
tout s'en va tout s'en va à l'électrique
donc mon est ce pétrolet est-ce qu'il va
être consommé ici ou va être exporté ou
les deux euh on exporte donc on produit
à peu près 4 millions de barils de
pétrole par jour au
Canada cis-moi pas là-dessus là mais ça
tourne autour de ça on exporte à peu
près 1 million de baril euh un peu plus
qu'un million de baril aux États-Unis
essentiellement notre capacité
d'exportation c'est c'est presque
exclusivement vers vers les États-Unis
donc onexporte pas en Europe ou il y en
a un petit peu là mais vraiment pas
beaucoup c'est surtout vers les
États-Unis
ok tantôt tu mentionnais les les bons
coups appelons ça comme ça les bons
coups que que que tu as fait dans les
dernières années simplement
puis en t'écoutant je me disais c'est
intéressant d'avoir cette conversation
puis dentendre parce que on les entend
pas c'est bon coup là on dirait que ça
se parvient pas jusqu'au monde fait que
c'est difficile de c'est difficile de
comme se sentir sentir ça va dans bonne
direction ou même j'imagine que pour toi
ça être difficile de faire on fait
quelque chose tu sais parce que moi on
en parlait l'autre fois la seule affaire
que j'entends quand qu'on parle de
politique ici en tout cas au Québec
c'est le trè lien c'est la seule affire
que j'entends par j'entends rien d'autre
il y a rien d'autre il y a rien qui
parvient les politiques fédérales les
actions comme ça on n entend pas parler
je vais te mettre sur ma liste d'envoie
ben si vous vouis sur ta newsletter mais
comment qu'on fait pour rejoindre les
gens ça ça se passe
puis sans que ça se fasse juste à H clos
qu'au final on a l'impression que le
gouvernement fait rien puis que il y a
rien qui se passe puis c'est sûr que il
y a un certain cynisme par rapport à la
politique en général on vit dans puis
c'est pas toujours comme ça ça ça pas
toujours été comme ça je pense pas que
ça va toujours être comme ça mais là
présentement on a des des gouvernements
très populistes dans il y a une vague
vraiment planétaire que ce soit en
Europe soit en Amérique latine que ce
soit aux États-Unis au Canada euh puis
il y a un phénomène médiatique aussi
puis je ne cherche pas ici à blammer les
médias mais tu sais la réalité c'est que
la la controverse les mauvaises
nouvelles ça ça fait vendre plus que les
bonnes nouvelles tu sais c'est rare que
un un un média va faire tu sais son son
grand titre avec quelque chose de
d'hyper positif tu sais on réduit 11000
baril de pétrole le fédéral réduit ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'équivalent de 11 millions de véhicules
ils vont en parler tu sais ça va être la
12e nouvelle ça va être si tu te rend en
bas de la page tu vois tu vas le voir
puis c'était comme ça moi je me souviens
quand j'étais chez kitaille producteur à
Radio Canada qui m'avait dit sais gamy
some blood Steven la controverse c'est
c'est ça qui alors il y a ça donc un
certain cynisme par rapport à la
politique tu euh les gens réalise pas
mais il y a un groupe de de de
chercheurs à l'Université Laval qui font
des études depuis très nombreuses années
sur le le respect des engagements
électoraux des promesses électorales h
puis encore une fois de mémoire là au
Canada puis c'est vrai aux États-Unis
aussi là en moyenne les partis
politiques vont respecter à peu près 77
78 % de leur promesse Mo des fois je
fais 77 77 77 à 78 là presque 80 % donc
ok trois promesses sur 4 on entend
surtout parler de de qui n'est pas moi
j'aurais pensé 50 % moi souvent je faire
des conférences puis je demande aux gens
vous pensez c'est quoi c'est c'est 0 à
25 % puis là tuas comme la moitié de la
salle qui lève la mainou puis là de de
25 à 50 un autre tiers puis là pour le
plus que 75 tu en a trois dans
qui écoute puis qui regarde la période
des questions sont au mon fils de 20 ans
il fait ça ouais
euh
alors puis c'est vrai les promesses
qu'on aime ou qu'on aime pas le
gouvernement de Stephen Harper a
respecté à peu près 80 % de ses
promesses dans notre premier mandat nous
selon ce groupe là on était à 90 % ok
donc de 2015 à 2019 mais la perception
c'est que les partis politiques puis
c'est c'est c'est vrai pour la CAC c'est
vrai pour pas mal tout le monde le
gouvernement Obama Trump j'ai pas j'ai
pas vu pour Trump ça c'est peut-être
plus compliqué dans Donal Trump là mais
en
moyenne mais c'est pas la perception que
les que les gens ont pour toutes sortes
de raisons ouais parce que les gens
s'intéressent c'est les gens
s'intéressent quand même un peu à la
politique mais il y a peu de gens qui
vont prendre le temps de regarder un peu
tout ce qui pas tout là mais une bonne
partie de sa d'analyser un peu tout ça
ça va vite tu travailles les enfants
maison boulot dodo
tu parlais de give me some
blood si on retourne un petit peu dans
dans ton passé
d'activiste quand tu regardes
aujourd'hui avec ton œil de ministre
mais avec le passé que tu as des actions
de d'activistes environnementaliste
radical comme on a vu justement au US
Open le gars se collé sur le banc se
coller les pieds sur sur dans les dans
les stand puis se mettre debout puis
crier puis interrompre toute la ente les
personnes qui se présentent dans les
musées d'ort pour lancer de la sauce
tomate c'est quoi ta perception de ça de
toi qui a déjà fait des stunt
radicaux pour attirer l'attention on
sait que c'est quelque chose c'est ça
que ça fait mais maintenant est-ce que
tu vois ça du même œil est-ce que est-ce
que toi tu trouves que c'est c'est
encore ça encore sa place c'est encore
pertinent de faire des des trucs comme
ça moi je pense que la la désobéissance
civile est un outil de changement social
qui qui qui a encore sa place
certainement puis c'est vrai pour
l'environnement c'est vrai pour des CAES
sociales ça a été un moteur de
changement dans nos sociétés on peut
penser Martin Luther King puis ce que
Gandy a fait en aind puis le mouvement
des des suffragettes ici pour le le
droit des femmes qui posait des gestes
d'éclat comme ça qu'elle pas la ten
mais moi je je je trace un peu la limite
où tu sais quand quand j'étais chez
Greenpace on faisait très attention de
de de ne pas tu sa si on coupait un can
parce qu'on rentrait quelque part on
apportait un en échange tu sais pour pas
s'attaquer à à la propriété on util bon
j'aiescaladé la tau de CEN on a utilisé
le la tour pour passer un message mais
on on détruisait pas de truc alors c'est
là où un peu donc moi j'ai un
malaise avec
le les quelques coups d'écloc qu'il y a
eu par rapport aux œuvres d'art sais moi
je pense qu' tu sais siil a bien si a
bien secteur qui qui qui a été un
vecteur et qui continue d'être un
vecteur de changement dans notre société
c'est les arts et la culture tu sais nos
poètes nos chanteurs nos écrivains nos
écrivaines alors moi je ouis moi je suis
malaise avec ça mais de façon générale
je très très très à l'aise avec ça puis
tu sa je pense que tu tu le fais parce
que tu penses que sa généralement les
gens ils vont faire ça parce qu'ils ont
essayé d'autres choses ils ont essayé
les pétition et on essayie de rencontrer
puis là ils estiment que mais en même
temps tu peux pas tout justifier avec ça
tu
mais moi pour moi la désobéissance
civile non violente a sa place aucun
regret
noncoute c'est drôle cette semaine il y
avait la première fois il y a 2 ans à la
conférence de Glasgow la COP 26 j'étais
avec le il y avait une section des chefs
d'État des leader j'étais avec le
Premier ministre Rudo puis on c'est bon
des fois il y a les discours tout ça
mais des fois il y a des petites tables
rondes on rentre dans une pièce il y a
40 personnes il y a le premier ministre
de Line n Rand de Moody il y a Boris
Johnson il y a la la premierre ministre
des Barbades qui est une voix forte là
pour les pays du Sud la premierre
ministre
montley il y a Boris Johnson et là je
suis assis derrière le Premier ministre
c'est le président Biden le président
Biden parle puis il reste un peu puis là
il se lève pour partir puis Premier
ministre se tourne vers moi puis dit
Steven tuas- déjà rencontré le président
Biden jamais rencontré le président
Biden fa qui d vient puis là tu sais il
y a comme les 12 gardes de sécurité
autour de Biden puis le Premier ministre
accroche le président par l'p puis dit e
Joe viens je te présente mon nouveau
ministre de l'Environnement c'est un
vrai militant il a été arrêté quatre
fois dans sa
vie présé CV arrêé qu fois c'est comme
ça que j'étais présenté au président des
États-Unis la première fois puis le
sincèrement le Premier ministre est très
fier de de de de ça tu sais de de se
passer là de de militant il s'en cache
jamais une fois
Infoman vous savez comment le travail de
recherche qu'il font là ils ont réussi à
mettre la main sur sur quelqu'un qui a
filmé le Premier ministre qui est avec
la ministre de la Défense à l'époque qui
était la ministre Anan et le le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN ils sont en
Europe puis là il font une visite de
quelque chose puis parle parle j j
ensemble puis le Premier ministre
raconte au secrétaire général de l' temp
que son ministre de l'Environnement
c'est un vrai militant écologiste un
vrai malade regarde des photos sont seul
puis là tu as ma collègue la minist Anan
sais qui est une qui est une avocate un
prof de droit un peu plus stit que moi
tu sais puis là tu vois dans son
regard dit il est pas vraiment en train
de dire ça au secrétaire général de l'
temp sais pu là quand je l'ai revu à la
Chambre des communes Anita j'ai dit j'ai
d comme ça le Premier ministre
embarrassé devant puis là elle était
toute mal à Steven écoute tu sa c'était
bien correct là mais ouais
euh alors moi je pense que le
militantisme a sa place évidemment dans
dans le mouvement écologiste dans les
mouvements sociaux mais tu peux être un
militant puis travailler pour une banque
tu peux être un militant puis travailler
pour une compagnie qui fait je sais pas
quoi tu peux être un puis tu peux être
un militant ou une militante en
politique aussi puis moi je pense qu'on
a besoin de gens tu sais si les gens qui
sont préoccupés par ces par ces
questions là vont pas en politique qui
va aller en politique défendre ces idées
là tu sais puis c'est sûr que c'est pas
facile des fois puis des fois tu fais
des choix qui sont qui sont pas
nécessairement tu es obligé de prendre
des décisions qui seraient qui serait
pas un choix que toi tu aurais fait
personnellement mais tu es pas juste là
à ton nom personnel ou ouais mais tu
sais on est on est embarqué dans le vif
du sujet tout suite dans le podcast mais
tu sais là c'est ben je suis curieux de
savoir en fait tu sais cette fibre là
indépend pas indépendantiste
Environnmental
c'est environnmentaliste
euh tu sais tu sais tu parlais de tu
sais tas fondé équitire je pense début
90 C fondé tu sais puis puis tu parlais
tantôt tu sais tu disais ça fait 30 ans
que tu 35 ans que que que tu fais du
vello à Montréal tu disais justement le
30 ans c'était pas la même urgence
climatique mais tu sais euh ça venait
d'où cette conviction là en fait d'un
sujet qui était à l'époque
moins moins populaire puis tu sais moins
moins urgent finalement ça ça a commencé
comment euh il y a une histoire qui
circule comme quoi quand j'avais 5 ans à
laatuc je viens de la
tuuc nous on habitait dans un nouveau
développement qui était la limite de la
ville puis là derrière la maison c'était
une forêt puis pendant des années cette
forêt là ça a été mon terrain de jeu
puis là un jour il ont commencé à la
couper pour faire un un plus nouveau
développement que notre nouveau
développement là je suis rentré dans la
maison puis j'ai dit à ma mère j'avais 5
ans tu sais puis je m ils sont en train
de couper notre forêt c'était pas nous
autres là mais pour moi tu sais le petit
gars que j'étais qu'est-ce qu'on fait ma
mère a dit bah tu Grimes dans un arbre
dit cel-à il pourront pas le couper moi
j'avais jouais qu'est-ce que je faisais
à longueur de journée je grimpais dans
armes fa que je suis grimpé dans un
armre puis je suis passé la journée là
puis là les travailleurs il voulaient le
couper puis là il disait descends mon
petit Chris non ma mère elle dit que je
peis être
site je suis resté là toute la
journée puis cette journéelà ils l'ont
pas coupé ils l'ont coupé éventuellement
quand j'étais à garderi la maternelle le
lendemain sur lendemain mais c'est la la
désillusion là cette journél où est-ce
que tu reviens chez vous cet là est
finalement coupé quand tu étais pas là
quand tu avais le dos tourné ben ça m'a
tu
sais je pense que j'ai j'ai certainement
pas réalisé à cet âge là euh ce qui se
passait mais je pense que tu sais avec
le temps cette cet épisode là m'a fait
prendre conscience de de l'importance de
de l'environnement puis de la protection
mais aussi du rôle qu'on peut jouer pour
essayer de de de de de le protéger ton
premier stun c'est c'est mon premier
d'un arbre à La Tuque à la tour du CEN
il il n'y a qu'un
pas puis donc après ça ça c'est toujours
resté comme ouais je m'impliquais
beaucoup au secondaire je me suis
impliqué après ça c'est à l'université
que que j'ai rencontré céibo qui est un
des cfondateurs qui est maintenant le
directeur de la transition écologique à
la Ville de Montréal lordur
Varidel François Meloche qui est un
expert en finance climatique qui qui
travaille qui travaille avec plein de
monde maintenant il avec le fond
d'action de la CSN tu sais alors c'est
là qu'on s'est rencontré puis qu'on a
qu'ondé quiit
h qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec les
plus acides on a régler ça parce que il
me semble que au secondaire c'était la
c'était de ça qu'on parlait là c'était
les plus tr d' C ouais ouais céit comme
les plus acides c'est la chose le gros
problème qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé essentiellement les les plus
assdes étent le résultat des émissions
de de de soufre d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises
beaucoup dans le secteur des des
industries lourdes puis on s'est rendu
compte qu'on pouvait mettre des filtres
puis enlever ça l'éliminer presque
totalement c'est ce qu'on a fait sa puis
y a eu des accords Canada États-Unis
euh de sorte que on a pas malélème pu
c'est la bonne nouvelle tu sais que ce
soit les plus acides tu parlais de la
couche d'osone la fin des années 80 tu
sais les cancers de la peau le trou dans
la couche d' zone pour les gens plus
âgés comme moi on on se souvient de ça
on en parlait beaucoup h là le trou dans
la couche d' zone on estime qu'il va
être presque totalement réparé d'ici
2060 on a signé à Montréal en
1987 le protocole de Montréal sur la
coue d'zone pour pour qu'on s'attaque à
ce problème là collectivement on en
parlait plutôt les les gens ils veulent
voir des progrès rapides ben la couche
auondes on a signé ça en 87 puis en en
2060 ça va être réglé ça va avoir appris
80 l'avoir vu tranquillement presque 80
ans eu on va encore parler du trè lien
rendu à ce moment-là j'espère j'espère
qu'on va parler encore c'est ça euh mais
ça montre aussi que on est un on est
capable de relever ces défis là quand on
se donne les moyens collectivement mais
que deux ça
plus la problématique est large plus ça
prend du temps tu sais là les
changements climatiques c'est
probablement l'un des plus grands défis
auquel l'humanité tu sais je veux dire
c'est le le pétrole le gaz et le charbon
aujourd'hui à l'échelle planétaire c'est
à plus de 70 % de notre portefeuille
énergétique alors c'est pas évident là
de se libérer de cette dépendance là la
couche d' zone c'était plus facile sa
c'était quelques produits chimiques qui
existaient des des des des des solutions
largement technologiques qu'on pouvait
mettre en place rapidement euh mais là
tu sais c'est c'est un problème qui est
complexe plus complexe donc ça prend
plus d'effort mais on est on est en
train d'y arriver hm hm hier j'ai écouté
un documentaire avec comment qui
s'appelle l'espèce d'aventurier anglais
là les rendu vieux là
ahonbor je l'ai rencontré l'année passée
ouais c'est un c'est un il était à la
conférence de légende en fait ce
garslvec la voix ouais tu fermes les
yeux puis tu l'écoutes c'est c'est
extraordinaire puis bref j'écoutéis
j'écouté son film puis là je l'ai pas
encore fini parce que il était tard mais
puis en fait ça fait un peu l'espèce
de l'historique de de sa vie tu sais
puis en même temps en parallèle de comme
à quel point la situation puis là c'est
beaucoup sous l'angle de la biodiversité
ouais puis là tu sais tu vois tu sais
quand commencé sa carrière dans les
années 50 pu ah ben la biodiversité
était déjà à 73 % tu sais de ce que de
ce qu'elle é avant avant l'homme moderne
mettons puis tu sais la vitesse à
laquelle on voit là j'étais rendu dans
les années 70 puis on est rendu à 55 %
puis les dit là jeéis allé voir ces
gorill là puis il en reste 300 puis
après ça il y en a plus tu sais puis
c'est fou parce que ça on se dit c'est
sa c'est il a des choses peut-être la
couche deut on peut la la renverser mais
la
biodiversité qui revendront pas là eff
c'est une
tristesse
tu tu as tout à fait raison
sa on perd des des espèces à un rythme
qui est équivalent à celui des grandes
périodes d'extinction qu'on a connu on
est les biologistes parlent de de la 6e
grande extinction ouais au même titre
que celle qui a fait disparaître les
dinosaures c'est le même rythme de
disparition des espèces qu'on connaît
que ce soit végétal ouou
animal
alors d'où l'importance avoir un accord
comme celui à Montréal en décembre
dernier la COP 15 on s'engage
collectivement à protéger au moins 30 %
de notre territoire et de nos océans
tout le monde incluant la Chine
incluant tout t tous les autres pays
même la Russie était là puis ont été
c'était un peu bizarre ça je dois vous
avouer là ouais un petit froid dans dans
pièce là ben puis moi je j'avais le
Canada était l'autre c'était c'était
c'était la Chine qui présidait la
rencontre parce que ça devait avoir lieu
en Chine mais à cause de la covid ça
pouvait pas avoir lieu puis là nous on a
proposé dit ben nous on peut on peut
être les l'autre de la rencontre sous
une présidence chinoise le ministre
chinois m'a demandé d'être l'un des des
cacilitateur donc de l'aider à trouver
un terrain d'entente et on faisait des
consultations avec différents pays puis
un soir tu sais je me suis ramassé dans
une salle on était 7 h don avec Don le
représentant de la Russie ça fait drôle
un peu quand même ça fait drôle is de
négocie sur d'A d'autres sujets mais ça
s très bien qu'en parallèle il y a des
atrocités qui se passent puis que mais
là on est pas là pour parler de ça mais
tu sais ça c'est c'est toujours quelque
chose qui me et vous votre transition
non mais mais c'est çais c'est toujours
quelque chose qui bug le cerveau tu des
États qui tu sa qui commettent des des
des atrocités puis mais puis là en même
temps on continue de faire du commerce
avec ces gens-là puis on d avoir des
relations avec ces gens-là c'est
toujours quelque chose qui me dépasse
mais je sais que c'est la politique
c'est complexe la diplomatie c'est c'est
ça tu sais c'est c'est que parfois il
faut que tu sois capable de de de de
compartimenter des choses dire ok là il
a a toutes ces affaires là qui ont pas
d'allure puis sur lesqueles on n pas
d'accord puis mais là on essaie de
trouver une entente là-dessus on est
capable de mettre nos différents de
côtés puis puis de de d'arriver à
d'arriver à ça alors tout ça pour dire
que on a une entente maintenant on va
protéger au moins 30 % puis on veut se
rendre à à ce que là à chaque année y a
un bilan qui est publié généralement au
mois de juillet qui dit bon ben là on a
on a utilisé plus de capital naturel que
la capacité de la planète à se rénérer
donc on un peu comme un compte en banque
quand tu dépenses plus que tes intérêts
ben le montant va diminueré il y en
restera plus ou on est quelqu'un qui con
chez vous puis ça va pas là l'année
passée pour la première fois depuis très
très très longtemps on la date a été
plus tardive donc on on dépense notre
capital naturel moins rapidement mais on
est encore en déficit hm hm l'objectif
essentiellement de la de la COP 15 à
Montréal c'est que d'ici 2050 on soit
positif d'un point de vue biodiversité
année après année et et non plus dans
dans le rouge al ça va nous prendre à
peu près 25 ans pour pour faire ça puis
on l' vu tu sais pendant la pandémie les
baleines qui qui étaient de retour dans
le la BA à Chicago on en a on a vu ça
aussi pas à Chicago mais à San Francisco
euh on a vu ça c'est aussi la nature a
cette capacité là de se régénérer très
rapidement j'ai eu la chance pendant 2
ans de travailler de très près avec
l'ancien ministre de l'Environnement au
Gabon il y a eu un coup d'état puis le
ministre de l'Environnement il est rendu
en Grande-Bretagne l'ancien ministre de
l'Environnement
mais ils ont fait des choses
extraordinaires pendant les derniers 15
20 ans au
Gabon 76 % du territoire est est protégé
je sais pas ce que va faire le nouveau
gouvernement là mais la population
éléphants au Gabon augmenté de 75 % au
cours des dernières années largement à
cause des politiques de protection de de
de la biodiversité que que le pays s'est
donné des pays en Afrique où les les
populations d'éléphants ont augmenté de
75 % il y en a pas des tonnes mais tout
ça pour dire que si on lui donne les
moyens de le faire si on lu donne un
bric finalement la nature est capable
mais tu as raison il y a des espèces tu
une fois qu'on a perdu une espèce on la
retrouve pas là à moins qu'on ait
confiance aveugle
ouais c'est quoi le film là sur les
dinosaures Jurassic par Jurassic Park ça
exact c'est à moins qu'on trouve une
manière de ressusciter les mamouts
comment qu' s'appelle la breobie qui a
été cloné Dolly Dolly ouais puis ça ça
si je me rappelle bien l'histoire
corrigez-moi si je me trompe ça la
brebie a été clonée puis là on a comme
collectivement fait W W W les le clonage
là je pense jeis pas pas genre ok là on
est allé peut-être genre On met la
là-dessus là mais ouais puis ils
sont aussi rendu compte
que les cellules ont une mémoire aussi
puis que même si tu essaie de prendre
des vieilles cellules pour créer un
nouvel être je pense qu'il y avait eu
des problèmes de vieillissement accéléré
aussi avec avec laabbie c'est comme si
les cellules se rapplent que sont pas
nouvelles finalement il on boêt dans une
nouvelle bébite là mais il y a une date
de péremption ah ouais ouais fait que
les milliardaires pourront pas se
clonner pour remplacer leurs
organes il y a ple des films ça je me
rappelle plus c'est quoi quand qu'on
parle environnement moi c'est un sujet
qui on parle des fois sur le Podcast
d'environnement puis moi je pose la la
même question à tout le monde qui vient
parler ici d'environnement parce que je
trouve que il y a un éléphant dans
pièces puis c'est tout ce qui est
l'alimentaire l'alimentation moi je suis
végétalien euh pour des raisons
environnementales en premier puis ça m'a
amené après ça évidemment m'intéresser à
l'éthique animale puis m'intéresser à
toutes ces enjeux-là de de de cruauté
animale puis de préservation mais on en
parle pas de l'alimentaire puis de
l'agroalimentaire puis à quel point
c'est une industrie qui est
essentiellement aussi nocive que le
transport quasiment là tu sais fait
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour pour ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
essayer parce que on s'entend que
prendre une voiture électrique à place
de prendre une voiture c'est un step qui
se fait bien tu continues à rouler de à
Z mais d'aller demander aux gens de
carrément changer leurs habitudes
alimentaires alors qu'on sait que ce
serait une avenue super pertinente c'est
plus difficile à faire c'est une pilule
qui est peut-être plus difficile à à
avaler ben c'est sûr que au Canada on en
parle jamais des campagnes électoral on
parle tout le temps de de
d'électrification des transports mais on
parle jamais de végétalisation de
l'alimentation c'est c'est sûr que c'est
plus facile pour un gouvernement de dire
on va vous aider à conduire une voiture
électrique que de de dire on va manger
du tofu on va faire en sorte que vous
mangez plus de viande c'est
alors au
Canada la première source de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
le pétrole et le gâaz à peu près à 27 %
après ça c'est le transport à 25 % le le
secteur agricole est autour de 8 % de de
de de nos émissions il y a des pays où
c'est plus élevé que ça je pense au
Brésil par exemple ou plus un pays va
s'industrialiser plus son secteur
agroalimentaire va va avoir une petite
part de ses émissions au profit des
industries du transport a les pays en
voie de développement généralement le
secteur agricole est plus élevé parce
que on brûle encore du bois puis on fait
on on brûle des grandes superficies pour
faire place à de
l'agriculture mais ici on a fait un
certain nombre de choses moi je pense
que le geste le plus important qu'on a
fait en tant gouvernement c'est de
changer le guide alimentaire il y a
quelques années on se rappelle du vieux
guide alimentaire quand on était petit
qui disait qu'il faut que tu manges
quatre portions de viande puis quatre
portions de de produits
puis le nouveau guide alimentaire sais
c'est tu peux manger de la viande tu es
pas
obligé tu peux boire du lait tu es pas
obligé tu vous dire que les producteurs
de bavin puis les producteurs tu pas
très content avec nous quand on a fait
ça puis tu sais il fait beaucoup de
place à l'alimentation à base de de
plantes fait que c'est pas on noublige
pas les gens mais mais par le puis on
sait à quel
point ce ce guide là joue un rôle
important dans les choix alimentaire des
des ménages fait moi je pense que ça
c'est c'est c'est très important
maintenant il faut bon j'ai adopté
récemment un nouveau projet de loi on a
modernisé la Loi canadienne sur la
protection de l'environnement mais il y
a tout un volet sur le les tests sur les
animaux également on les a presque
éliminé là il faut vraiment que tu te
lèves de bonheur en tant que chercheur
tu veux faire des tests sur les animaux
euh au Canada et les les groupes de
protection des animaux ont salué ce ce
ce projet de loi là euh c'est pas
exactement lié à ce que tu dis mais j'ai
un autre projet de loi qui s'en vient
sur les animaux en captivité aussi euh
mais qui s'intéresse à la question du
bien-être animal ce projet de loi là va
être déposé bientôt alors c'est vrai
qu'on en parle moins tu sais comme
ministre de l'Environnement tu fais des
choix tu sais je me suis attaqué au au
deux secteur qui représente plus de en
priorité plus de la moitié de nos
émissions de gaz effet au Canada ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut ignorer les a autres
mais il y a juste 24 heur dans une
journée fait que tu choisis tes tes
batailles mais je pense que tu aurais tu
l'ancien président du G disait tout le
monde devrait pas mal être végétarien ou
manger le moins de viande possible
est-ce qu'on pourrait ce qui est
difficile pour le fils d'un boucher moi
mon père était bouché à la TUC je mange
pas beaucoup de viande j'agette ma
viande d'une ferme c'est bio c'est c'est
local c'est c'est Free range mais je
dois avouer que je mais parce que ce
type de consommation plus c'est c'est
c'est impossible de l'appliquer à la
société au complet donc ça veut
effectivement dire que
tu ça veut dire qu'il faut repenser tout
ce système là industriel
puis je pense que ça ça doit faire
partie de la conversation au même tire
qu'on au même titre qu'on parle de notre
dépendance au pétrole et de de de
réduire éventuellement éliminer notre
dépendance au pétrole je pense qu'il
faut avoir ce genre de conversation là
aussi même si l'industrie des je enc
encore moins populaire en Alberto ou non
c'est ça c'est ça mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est ça il doit avoir quand même
pas mal de ben on l'a vu ici en boss là
quand
le quand il y a eu les
élections 5 ans je crois où est-ce que
là c'était la cque qui a rentré au lieu
de
euh son nom maintenant maim ber au lieu
de Maxime Bernier parce que Maxime
Bernier avait amené une une une idée sur
le lait là sur la la la la la gestion de
l'offre ouais exact exact les lobis
laitiers ont comme décidé de bquer le
candidat la cque conservateur exa oua
ouais puis ça comme ça ça ça l' tout
changé l'élection là tu sais fa c'est
des lobis qui sont encore super fort
écoute des
ok c au fédéral c'est ça mon mon mémoire
euou ouais je me souviens des lobby euh
il y en a beaucoup tu sais à tous les
jours pas tous les jours là mais tu sa
le lobby de l'O ouais euh le lobby du
pétrole le lobby du gaz
euh puis il y a un lobby agricole très
important qui sur C sur la question de
de la lutte au changement climatique tu
c'est les producteurs de grains les
producteurs laitiers les producteurs de
de de volail ils se sont tous engagés à
être carbone neutre puis commencent à
mettre en place des mesures alors je
pense que c'est des gens qui qui qui
évoluent euh puis bon jusqu'où ils vont
être prêts à aller tu sais puis puis en
même temps
faut pas c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
lobby qui faut qu'il a tout le temps
raison ça se peut qu'il a raison des
fois ça se peut qu'il y a pas raison des
fois puis si tu à nous à les challenger
puis des fois d moi je quand je
rencontre lobby de l'automobile
sincèrement sont presque pire que ceux
du pétrole ah ouais je parlais de la loi
zéro émission tu sais pour forcer le les
forcer à mettre plus de véhicules zéro
émission sur le marché puis là ils me
disent ils vont me dire mettons ils vont
me dire ah mais vous devriez pas faire
votre propre règlement au Canada vous
devriez prendre CELI lui des États-Unis
parce que l'Agence de protection
environnementale aux États-Unis est en
train de faire ce qu' ce que nous aussi
on fait au Canada mais ce qu'il disent
pas c'est qu'il poursuivent aux
États-Unis l'Agence de protection de
l'environnement fait qu'ils disent non
faites le pas au Canada faites ce que
les États-Unis vont faire puis là
pendant ce tempsl ils
poursuivent les les Américains ENF tout
ça pour dire que tu sais je veux dire
puis il y a des lobby environnementaux
aussi les groupes écologistes un lobby
les
SIC c'est sû que oui oui les moyens sont
son ce sont pas les mêmes ça c'est c'est
c'est tout à fait vrai c'est quoi en
fait sais l'influence de ces lobby là
puis leur pouvoir en fait c'est quoi
leur leur pouvoir de négociations avec
vous en fait qui ont le lobby du pétrole
des automobile tout ça ben tu
sais ils ont autant de pouvoir que tu
leur en donnes h fait que sais moi ils
vont me demander à me rencontrer puis là
ils vont me dire ah mais vos règles sont
la dernière fois j'ai rencontré les gens
de l'automobile je leur ai raconté quand
j'étais chez équitaire puis qu'on
travaillait sur le la mise en place du
système de de tarification carbone au
Québec le le système de plafonnement et
d'échange d'émission de gaz effet ser il
y a un représentant de l'industrie du
ciment qui était vraiment très proactif
il était engagé dans les conversations
puis pas pour mettre les briques mais tu
sais pour travailler de façon
constructive puis un momentné je dit je
trouve ça vraiment super que tu sois
impliqué comme ça mais tu sais ça va
t'impacter ça va impacter ton ton
enfant qu'est-ce tu sais qu'est-ce que
ça implique je je comprenais pas puis il
me dit il dit tu sais Steven il ditmi il
dit j'aime mieux être autour de la table
qu'être sur le menu ouais ah j'ai fait
ouais tu sais dans le sens où ça s'en
vient tu sais je peux choisir de dire oh
je veux rien savoir ou je peux m'assur
m'asseoir à la table avec vous puis
travailler à ce que ce soit le meilleur
règlement possible puis euh puis j'ai
dit à au gens d' l'industrie de l'auto
ben j'ai dit bon vous avez une heure
avec moi vous pouvez être assez autour
de la table vous pouvez être sur le menu
à vous déci
puis il ont décidé d'être au
menu ont passé ils ont passé une heure à
me dire ah vous devriez pas faire ça
puis là je leur ai dit à fin de l'heure
je dis vous avez compris qu'on va le
faire puis vous avez passé vous avez
perdu une heure vous auriez puengager tu
dire ah mais cette partie là de
règlement avez-vous pensé le faire comme
ça plutôt que comme ça parce que on a
pas tout le temps raison nous autres non
plus puis tu quand tu fais un nouveau
règlement nouvelle loi tuessaie de faire
laess de mettre quel chose construire la
meilleure option possible mais des fois
tu vois pas tout pas alors ça se peut
que c'est pour ça qu'on fait des projets
de loiis là les gens débattent puis tu
fais des modifications mais je vous
venez de perdre une heure puis des
heures comme ça j'en ai pas plein à vous
donner meilleure chance la prochaine
fois finalement tu
sais ils ont du pouvoir si tu leur en
donnes puis tu dis ben
écoute to
badad il pas de pouvoir
je
comprends même si dis on va baquer votre
votre adversaire politique ça fait pas
m'ont menacé de il m'ont pas menacé
directement mais il ont dit au gens de
mon équipe on va lancer une campagne de
publicité contre le ministre guilbau
puis parfait free
public ils vont parler de moi ils vont
dire que je fais quelque chose pour
l'environnement avec ça quand la
Première ministre de l'Alberta m'attaque
tous les jours ou presque sur les médias
sociaux je suis pas Sr que c'est une
mauvaise affaire pour Steven guilb
ministre de l'Environnement du
Canada puis sais que les les compagnies
pétrolières m'accuse d'être un
extrémiste ou radicaux
environnementaux pas sûr qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui croient quand ils
disent ça mais bon faut que tu sois prêt
à tu sois prêt à ce qu'il a un peu de
chaleur des fois à VI avec ça ouaou non
mais excuse Contin làdessus mais en même
temps en ce moment clairement il y a
quand même un
discours plus list de droite qui
raisonne parce que en ce moment dans les
sondages les partie conservateur est
quand même pierre polière est quand même
populaire puis avec un discours
complètement pratiquement
climatoceptique là tu
sais tu sais dans la publicité qu'on a
vu cet été puis il parle pas de ces
questions là il parle pas des questions
difficiles tu sais il parle de la
question de l'abordabilité puis des taux
d'intérêt puis de l'inflation mais il
veut pas qu'on lui pose des questions
sur le droit des femmes de chois parce
que dans sa gangne y a plein de divis
oui puis s'il prend le pouvoir tu sais
c'est sûr qu'il va avoir des projet de
loi puis il y en a eu un qui a été
présenté par une de ses députés il y a
pas longtemps sur le droit du fitus
alors il parle pas de droit à
l'environnement de de droit aux femmes
de de choisir mais là céit c'était sur
le droit des fitus euh sur la question
de des changements climatique tu la la
position officielle du parti c'est qu'il
ne croit pas au changement climatique
mais il en parle il en parle jamais si
il veut pas alors c'est sûr que mais
c'est quand même incroyable de de
publiquement te prononcer comme ne pas
croire au changement climatique lui en
parle pas mais mais c'est dans sa dans
son son le l'avantdernier parce que au
dernier congrès il ont pas parlé de
changement climatique celui qui à Québec
mais l'avant-dernier c'est là où il y a
une résolution qui a été adoptée par les
membres du parti qui disait on ne
reconnaît pas la la réalité des
changements climatiques mais Pierre poli
va jamais dire ça il va jamais en parler
parce qu'il veut pas ça se peut qu'il se
fasse poser la question quand VI le temp
arver sur le sujetis les sondages c'est
important juste bloqué
les les sondages c'est important puis
bon tu en politique tu regardes ça mais
je parlais à un sondeur qui me disait
les sondages politiques quand tu es pas
en campagne électorale c'est un peu
comme quelqu'un qui t'appelle puis qui
dit e toi tu cherches un auto tu dis non
je suis pas vraiment sur le marché pour
un auto mais mettons que tu cherchera
une auto puis là tu dis bah ouais ok je
dois répondre à tes questions mais je
suis pas sur le marché pour un auto fait
mes réponses ça vaut ce que ça vaut
ouais plus on va s'approcher d'une
campagne électorale plus euh tu sais là
ça va devenir sérieux puis là les gens
vont porter attention à ça mais là
présentement les gens ils sont pas ils
sont pas là-dedans puis euh il y a son
il y a un sondeur qui me qui me
présentait quelque chose au congrès du
du Parti libéral qui nous a montré une
acétate tu sais où euh les conservateurs
étaient en av sur nous de 14 15 points
et puis là il disait c'est 30 de points
de plus en en Atlantique puis en Ontario
puis en Colombie Britannique nous parle
de ça pendant 10 minutes puis là tuétait
comme ouais ça va être tough tu sais ah
disccusé j'ai oublié de de mettre la
date sur mon assetat avril 2019 oh tu
sais c'est pas la première fois où les
sondages puis quand tu es au
gouvernement c'est sûr que tu prends des
décisions puis il y a des décisions que
les gens aiment puis y a des décisions
que les gens aiment pas puis plus tu es
là longtemps tu sais plus les gensé le
goût de changement moi je pense que la
prochaine campagne électorale va être
essentiellement autour de d'un certain
nombre de choses mais y a une partie des
gens qui vont dire ben là les libéux ça
fait 10 ans que vous êtes là tu sa on a
peut-être le goût de changement mais ils
vont se dire ok mais je veux su vraiment
c'est seul changement tu sais ce gars là
pierre pulè puis moi je pense que tu sa
ses positions puis les positions de son
parti là il peut essayer de s'en cacher
mais en campagne électorale ça va être
plus difficile mais je pense qu' aussi
il va y avoir des enjeux comme les
changements climatiques
où les gens vont se dire on veut d voter
pour un parti qui va nous ramener en
arrière sur sur sur ces questionsl alors
je pense que il est populaire maintenant
dans les sondages je pense qu'il faut
pas paniquer en même temps on a du
travail à faire il faut regagner la
confiance des gens puis c'est sûr qu'en
période difficile comme celle qu'on
traverse une forte augmentation des des
taux
d'intérêt l'inflation les gens sont un
sa c'est tough pour bien du monde puis
là ben quand c'est tough ils sont fâchés
contre leur liader ouais alors est-ce
que ça sera encore comme ça dans un an
dans un an et demi on verra commencer de
ça fait plusieurs fois tu sais que tu
mentionnes que en Alberta tu irais pas
puis dans dans en Atlantique tu irais
pas non plus tu laisses ça descendre
c'est c'est comment de diriger un pays
aussi euh on n'est pas le pays le plus
divisé tu sais on a juste à regardé aux
États-Unis pour voir c'est quoi de la
vraie division mais c'est quoi diriger
un pays quand même o est-ce qu'
des
provinces qui sont quand même vraiment
fondamentalement différent comme le
Québec puis l'Alberta par exemple mais
moi je ferais la je ferais une
distinction entre les la population de
ces provinces là puis les gouvernements
puis bon tu dis sa c'est les gens qui
lisent les gouvernements c'est vrai mais
la dernière élection en Alberto ça a été
très serré entre le NPD c'est quand même
assez incroyable en Alberto c'est entre
NPD puis les conservateurs puis là
vraiment une version conserv hyper
conservateurou on est un peu dans les
extrêmes puis c'est quelques milliers de
votes qui a fait en sorte que c'est
c'est Daniel Smith qui est passé puis
pas r
Dantley 1 de il y a un sondage qui est
sorti récemment qui montrait deux deux
sondages qui sont sortis récemment qui
montraiit que il y a à peu près 60 60 %
des Albertains qui veulent que le
gouvernement fédéral mette un plafond
sur les émissions de gaz à effet de s du
secteur du pétrole et du gaz alors je
suis pas tu sais je vois pas je vois pas
en Nouvelle-Écosse ou je vois pas en
Alberta pas parce que les gens ils vont
me tirer des roches quand je vais aller
là mais c'est sûr qu'il y a des gens qui
m'aiment vraiment pas beaucoup là mais
il y en a aussi des gens au Québec qui
m'êent pas beaucoup mais surtout parce
que les relations avec le avec ces
gouvernements là sont sont plus tendu
puis je veux pas non plus chercher à
acheter de l'huile sur le feu mais en
même temps avec la Nouvelle Écosse on
vient de signer une accord sur la
conservation h HM euh on en on en a
signé une avec le le Yukon suite à la
suite à la COP 15 donc où on s'engage
ensemble à travailler à atteindre
l'objectif de protéger au moins 30 % de
nos terres et de nos océans fait même
chose si on parlait de la Chine puis de
de de deine puis même au niveau du
Canada des fois il y a pas autant de
deimosité ouais c'est ça de différence
entre le le gouvernement fédérale puis
la Nouvelle Écosse mant mais il y a des
choses sur lesquelles on s'entend pas
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on est pas
capable de se parler puis ensemble
et et et même tu de façon presque
paradoxale l'année passée j'ai renégocié
avec le gouvernement albertin de Daniel
Smith une tarification carbone plus
ambitieuse en Alberta parce que le le
système fédéral de de de prix sur la
pollution on donne l'option aux aux
provinces comme le Québec qui a son
propre système puis tu peux avoir ton
système à toi où tu peux utiliser le
système fédéral en autant que ça soit à
peu près équivalent pu on a des formules
bien bien savantes pour essayer de
calculer l'équivalence puis on a dit à
l'Alberta vous avez un système puis
votre système il fonctionne vous vous
pouvez le garder mais il faut il faut
ser à vis puis j'ai réussi à négocier ça
elle n' parlera jamais publiquement tu
elle aimerait mieux être crucifié que
que que d'avouer publiquement tu sais
que qu'elle a fait ça avec Steven
guilbaau tu sais mais elle l'a
fait bonne crucifiction c'est moins pire
c'est moins pire que d' d'avoir été en
accord avec le ministre de
l'Environnement faire arracher une d
frette ça serait moins difficile pour
elle est-ce que la la
politique ça ça une date de de péromtion
pour toi oui oui oui moi je tu
sais je pense que tu il y a toutes
sortes de monde en politique puis il y a
toutes sortes de raisons pour lesquelles
les gens vont en
politique je je me vois pas comme un
politicien de carrière j'ai attendu tu
sa que mes enfants soient plus vieux
avant d'y aller parce que je voyais je
travaillais avec beaucoup de de
politicien de politicienne puis je
voyais à quel point c'était c'était
exigeent sur sur sur sur la vie
notamment la vie personnelle fait que
j'ai attendu mais je pense pas je dois
faire ça pendant 20 ans moi je je je
suis allé là pour pour aider mon pays à
donner un coup de barre sur ces
questions là je dois faire ça pendant un
bout de temps puis après ça je je va
faire d'autres choses encore en
environnement fort probablement je sais
pas quoi
mais mais bon je vais être là aux
prochaines élections c'est sûr tu
resterais-tu comme député dans
l'opposition m temp ben si je veux dire
je je mettons que on perd les prochaines
élections mais que je suis je suis élu
je vais faire mon mandat comme député tu
sa je veux pas je pense que tu es pas là
juste pour être au gouvernement
tuespères être au gouvernement c'est sûr
tuespères pouvoir avoir le
plus avoir le plus de de d'outils pour
faire changer les choses tu en moins
dans l'opposition que quand tu es
gouvernement c'est certain mais en même
temps c'est ça la démocratie aussi tuis
tu peux tu peux gagner tu peux perdre tu
peux gagner comme député puis ton parti
peut perdre les élections hm hm h HM
est-ce que euh tu as eu
une un gain depuis que que tu es au
gouvernement que tu es dans dans le
gouvernement en fait qui qui était sans
aucun compromis 100 % comment tu
l'aurais pris
puis puis sinon c'est quoi ton gain
duquel tu es le plus
fier ben non j'ai jamais S pour ça
jamais jamais euh mais tu sais tout ce
dont j'ai parlé un peu plusôt dans dans
l'émission tu sais c'est tu regardes les
déclarations de plusieurs écologistes
mêmees mes anciens collègues et et
toujours amis de de Greenpace qui ont
certains ont affirmé publiquement
que on n jamais vu autant d'action en
environnement de la part d'un
gouvernement au Canada et c'est pas
juste il y a plusieurs représentants de
groupes écologistes qui qui l'ont dit
même Mme certains journalistes qui
commencent à l'affirmer alors pour moi
c'est ça qui est important sa est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on est en train de
donner le coup de barre qui est
nécessaire mais je pense qu'on il y a eu
plusieurs succès toutes ces mesures là
qu'on a réussi écoute là je dois déposer
bientôt le projet de règlement pour
mettre un plafond sur les émissions de
gaz effet ser du secteur du pétrole et
du gaz au Canada tu sa on est le seul
pays au monde à faire ça puis on est le
4e plus grand producteur de pétrole et
de gaz sur la planète
sais tu dis je vis mettre un plafond sur
les émissions de gaz à effets du pétrole
et du gaz mais on n pas de pétrole et de
gaz dans notre pays ça coûte pas trop
cher tu sais
euh c'est quand même majeur tu sais ça
ça veut dire des des des dizaines de
millions de tonnes de produ de de de
pollution en moins de de de ce secteur
là on ne jamais vu ça au pays jamais
jamais jamais tu sais c'est c'est majeur
mais bon si j'avais été tout seul dans
ma chambre chez nous pu j'avais fait le
règlement il il il aurait probablement
été plus ambitieux que ce que mais bon
tu faut il y a des tu en parlais plutôt
il y a des enjeu de de il y a
l'environnement il y a il y a l'économie
il y a les emplois il y a on est bien
prêt à se poignner avec avec moi je suis
bien prêt à me poignner avec des
provinces mais tu veux pas non plus tu
sais il faut que tu essayes de garder on
essaie de garder la Fédération quand
même un fa tu mets tout ça ensemble
fait tu fais des compromis mais ce qui
est important pour moi c'est qu'on
puisse continuer d'avancer dans la lutte
au changement climatique j'aurais pas
100 % mais si j'ai 80 % de ce que je
veux c'est mieux que zéro tu sais c'est
mieux que le vide absolu dans lequel on
était avant 2015 h je vouis te poser une
question qui sort du sujet de
l'environnement qui pas je pense qu'on a
le
droit parler d'autres choses mais c'est
pas un sujet le fun à parler je
t'avertis suite euh c'est pas un sujet
qui concerne le
non plus non ok non pas
vraiment mais en fait tu sais euh c'est
plus tu sais en tant que membre du
gouvernement que je te pose la question
tu sais parce que tu sais en ce moment
c'est un sujet d'actualité fait que je
tant qu'avoir un un Politien devant moi
je posé les questions euh ben tu sais en
ce moment mettons ce qui se passe en en
Israël en Palestine je pense que tu sais
tout le monde en tout tout mon entourage
moi tout le monde parle de ça tout le
monde regarde ça tout le monde est
horrifié tout le monde puis tout le
monde se sent puissant en fait parce que
tu sais je veux dire le simple citoyen
il regarde ça puis dit je voudrais juste
la paix mais tu sais concrètement on
peut rien faire par contre un
gouvernement d'un pays j'imagine peut
faire quelque chose en fait ma question
c'est qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire pu
qu'est-ce que vous faites pour essayer
de de de de de de de que ce conflit là
continue pas de s'envénimer puis de
de honnêtement même comme gouvernement
c'est c'est c'est un défi tu sais on
voit qu'il y a plusieurs gouvernements
de la planète qui essaient de trouver
une solution à ce conflit là incluant
les États-Unis d'Amérique depuis
plusieurs années avec des succès mettons
mitigés jusqu'à date
h je pense qu'
sa je pense qu'il faut faire preuve de
d'équilibre dans dans dans notre au
départ quand il y a eu l'attaque du
Hamas le Premier ministre sévèrement
dénoncé ça mais
on a aussi dit que tu sais la protection
des civils en en Palestine est tout
aussi importante que la protection des
civils en Israël il peut pas avoir deux
poids de mesures contrairement au
président Biden par exemple qui est déjà
sorti pour dire NON la l'attaque sur
l'hôpital qu'on a vu c'est pas les
Israéliens euh nous on a on a le premier
ministre a dit attendons un peu tu sais
puis on n pas les Américains on
rapidement pris le le côté d'Israël mais
la France sont quand même bons amis là
en fait lesou ou il a une relation très
étroite mais la France la
Grande-Bretagne l'Allemagne comme le
Canada on dit attendons un peu tu sais
on n'est pas sûr on veut on veut creuser
au fond des choses al je pense que tu
peux pas espérer pouvoir jouer un rôle
dans ce conflitl en étant dans un camp
ou dans l'autre il faut que il faut tu
peux travailler avec tout le monde puis
tu dois travailler avec tout le monde la
la miné jolie y était la la fin de
semaine dernière elle a rencontré plein
de monde que ce soit du côté israélien
du côté
Arab le Premier ministre a parlé au chef
de l'Autorité
palestinienne aussi puis on essaie de
travailler avec d'autres pays pour voir
c'est ça ressemble à quoi une sortie de
crise puis ça ressemble à quoi une
solution à plus long terme c'est pas
facile c'est ça fait je veux dire ça
fait des décennies qu' qu'il y a des
conflits dans cette région là du
monde ça prend de la volonté de tout le
monde puis là présentement tu tant du
côté palestinien que du côté israéliens
c'est les extrémistes qui mènent
Benjamin netanahou c'est pas un artisan
de la paix puis c'est au contraire puis
la hass non plus je c'est pas des gens
qui la hass les victimes civiles
palestinienne ils s'en foutent comme
dans l'an 40 c'est un régime de terreur
même pour les Palestiniens tu peux pas
être tine puis critiquer le
Hance tu peux pas être un membre du
Hance puis y a des chefs chef politique
du Hance qui s'est fait
arrêter par par les Israéliens puis il a
un peu condamné l'attaque de la branche
militaire du Hamas puis là
j'entendais je pense à la BBC mais
quelqu'un dire une chance qui s'est fait
arrêter par les Israéliens parce que
sinon la mass l'aurait tué sais al il
faut il faut qu'il y a des
voix Mo moins extrémiste de part et
d'autre qui soit prêt à s'assoir à la
table puis essayer de trouver une
solution puis là on a de la misère à
trouver ces interlocuteurs là h je
comprends je pense tout le monde
s'entend tout le monde s'entend pour
dire que d'un côté ou de l'autre un
innocent qui qui meurt un civil qui
meurt les gens sont pas leur
gouvernement puis il sont pas
responsables de quoi que ce soit là tu
sais puis que c'est c'est toujours une
tragédie quand que ça arrive mais j'ai
l'impression je suis vraiment pas expert
dans la politique et Moyen Orient
ministreenvironnement sauf que tu sais
j'ai quand même l'impression quand tu
regardes quand même ces deux peuples
là quand même un peu plus opprimé que
l'autre j'ai l'impression tu sais puis
on dirait qu'à l'international on est on
est frileux de de on dit c'est un
conflit entre deux entités
mais en tout cas moi je trouve ça dur de
pas pas
avoir une empathie particulière pour un
peuple qui qui qui est opprimé depuis
longtemps là je parle des palestiniens
en tout cas c'est c'est une solution
c'est c'est une situation qui est qui
qui est vraiment difficile puis tu c'est
particulièrement difficile de voir
présentement même si on parle pas de de
de solution à long terme mais juste à
court terme c'est quoi la c'est quoi la
solution ou les solutions qui doivent
être mises en place c'est c'est
difficile de mais bon je pense que il
faut ça il y a beaucoup d'efforts
présentement au niveau inter nationaux
pour essayer de de trouver cette
solutionl
ou ces solutions là puis le Canada est à
la table avec plusieurs partenaire mais
mais je pense que le le fait
qu'on moi je préfère être un pays qui
qui est pas identifié à un parti ou à
l'autre qui dit écouteter là il faut
protéger les civils de de part et
d'autre puis il faut il faut qu' il faut
qu'il y ait un arrêt de la violence
avant qu'on puisse espérer trouver une
une autre forme de solution moi j'aime
mieux qu'on soit là que dans un camp qui
dit non non nous on est 100 % avec un
des camp versus l'autre sais je pas sûr
que c'est la bonne approche je comprends
h yes sir dernière petite question avant
de te laisser aller on retourne à
l'environnement c'est quoi la note
environnementale de Steven gilbau pour
la
[Rires]
caque
écoute de A à
E puis d moins c'est c'est un échec ok
honnêtement moi je je répondrai pas à ta
question directement surprise ok ok je
suis sûr que vous êtes sous le choc
mais moi je m'entends très très bien
avec le ministre de l'Environnement du
Québec BO Charret qui est un gars que je
connais depuis avant que la CAC prenne
le pouvoir quand j'étais chez kitire on
a travaillé ensemble il était dans
l'opposition puis c'est lui qui avait
fait le le plan de transport qui était
la base l'un des éléments de la campagne
électorale de la CAC avant qu' qu'il
prenne le pouvoir je trouvais c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille bien puis qui
qui qui qui est consciencieux puis c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui qui parle qui avec
je m'entends bien qui est parlâ
puis on a
eu un grand différent avec le Québec sur
la question du caribou l'ancien ministre
qui était responsable de ça c'était
sincèrement une
catastrophe pour le caribou puis pour
les relations avec les autochtones d'un
point de vue d'un point de vue politique
ce gars c'était sais les Anglais on
pression qui disent gift that keeps on
giving c'est un cadeau qui fait tout le
continant des cadeaux parce qu'il
faisait des déclarations qui avait pas
de bon sens puis politiquement c'était
super payant pour moi mais ça fait pas
des enfants fort tu construis pas
grandchose là c'est c'est c'est le
Ministre charrette maintenant qui a la
responsabilité de ça puis on devait
arriver à une entente avec le caribou
avec le Québec sur le caribou pour juin
dernier il y a eu les feux de forêt
Québec a dit on a besoin d'un peu plus
de temps puis je comprends ça on doit on
doit arriver à cette
là en novembre maintenant euh alors on n
pas d'accord sur tout mais on travaille
ensemble sur tout tout le volet de
l'électrification des
transports les les composantes de de
batteries pour pour les voitures
électriques les usine de batteries on a
fait beaucoup d'annonces conjointes
c'est le retour de GM au Québec l'usine
de
norvt euh alors on est on est capable de
travailler ensemble on n pas d'accord
sur tout mais qui est important c'est
qu'on puisse avoir cette cette
collaboration là sur les changements
climatiques le Québec est un liader
depuis longtemps on est le premier état
en Amérique du Nord qui a mis un prix
sur la pollution avant la Californie
avant qui que ce soit et ce qui est
fascinant du Québec et j'espère que ce
soit comme ça un jour au fédéral aussi
c'est
que il y a des partis provinciaux qui
sont peut-être plus pro environnement
que d'autres mais il y a pas tu sais la
CAC dit pas non nous on croit pas ça les
changements climatiques puis tu comp
c'est un parti peut-être le C plus à
droite que certainement nous on l' au
fédéral
euh mais ça a rien à voir avec le le
Parti conservateur du Canada alors on
est capable de travailler ensemble sur
un paquet de dossiers on s'entend pas
surtout la question de la langue plus
tof mettons euh mais sur les dossiers en
environnement en général changement
climatique le Québec on se prépare à
aller à la COP le Québec va avoir la la
plus grande délégation de toutes les
provinces canadiennes et de loin en fait
si le Québec tu sais probablement une
délégation à la à la COP qui est plus
grande que la plupart des pays de la
planète il y a vraiment une engouement
tu as des gens d'affaires les ONG je
parlais à la FT cuillère il va avoir une
dizaine de représentants à la COP tu
sais c'est c'est un mouvement de société
qu' qu'on qu'on voit qui se reflète
là-dedans ça ça m'encourage beaucoup h
si c'était comme ça partout au pays tu
sais même si c'était des gouvernements
de droit dans des provinces mais qui
étaient pro lutte au changement
climatique ce serait plus facile pour
moi ouou mett ça comme ça j'éci la
répon de ce que j'
comprend merci
beaucoup vraim
intéress